but we begin with the polls the polls
across the country are now open
you can see people in charlottesville
virginia casting their ballots early
this morning
millions are expected to vote across the
nation today
on top of an estimated record of nearly
100 million
early voters have already stood in line
and voted joe biden spent his last
moments on the trail in pennsylvania
it's a state that could be pivotal
in deciding this race one of the
president's last campaign rallies was in
wisconsin one of the key midwestern
states that helped him win the white
house
in 2016. the latest cbs news
battleground battle tracker poll
shows president trump trailing joe biden
by seven points
in the contest for wisconsin wisconsin's
ten electoral votes
adriana diaz is outside a polling place
in milwaukee this morning adriana good
morning to you
good morning polling places like this
one just opened their doors and
people have been trickling in but listen
to this historically on average
six percent of people usually vote by
mail here in wisconsin
this year an estimated 60 to 80 percent
of folks voted by mail
and that's due in part of course to
covet that has led to record-breaking
early voting numbers here in wisconsin
now nearly 2 million early votes just
started being processed and counted at 7
00 a.m
so really there's no guarantee that
we'll have a declared winner here
tonight
the trump campaign has criss-crossed
wisconsin at least
17 times since the pandemic began
compared to just four visits from joe
biden and kamala harris
the president won in 2016 by just under
23 000 votes who could forget that
that is less than one percent this year
despite being outspent here and behind
in the polls
wisconsin trump supporters we spoke with
believe in his record
he aligns much more with my
ideals one thing the abortion issue
also i go hunting so i'm gun owner
and the economy is a huge issue also
joe biden is trying to flip wisconsin
back to blue in 2016 when president
trump won
he was the first republican to win this
state since ronald
reagan anthony adriana thank you